You've heard
the adage
those who fail to learn from his
are doomed to repeat it.
But what about those
who rewrite the past?
Well, that's
exactly what millions of America
who tuned into Fox
are this week after House Speake
Kevin McCarthy released
a trove of new
January six
security footage
exclusively to Tucker Carlson.
Now, McCarthy's controversial de
is reopening
deep divisions within his own pa
about the Capitol attacks.
And just last night,
former Vice President
Mike Pence had this to say
at the annual Gridiron Dinner
about his former boss
and some of his fellow Republica
said President Trump was wrong.
I had no right to overturn the e
and his reckless words endanger
and everyone at the Capitol that
And I know that history will hol
Donald Trump accountable.
Make no mistake about it.
What happened that day was a dis
and it mocks decency
to portray it in any other way.
It's interesting that he decided
to say this last night
and draw this really sharp
contrast with Donald Trump
in absolutely was.
And it's farther than he's gone
He's talked about the security
of his family before, but this w
a calling out the former preside
But what he's not
done is sort of accepted the inv
to come and testify
at any of the hearings on Januar
In fact, he's resisting that.
So some may say
perhaps a bit convenient for him
to make this in a closed
press setting, basically
without cameras there.
But the fact that he did say it,
I think
is quite significant
regardless of the venue in the f
The question for the former vice
president politically, as he goe
and tries
to potentially run for president
there's really no appetite for t
But this is one of the strongest
we've seen him make from Donald
Does it matter in the long run?
I'm not necessarily sure
who is listening
to Mike Pence at this point.
Why do you think right now
he chose this moment to do this?
I mean, certainly Pence is one o
We've talked
about a number of Republicans
who are looking to potentially r
for president.
He's been out.
He's been in early states.
So but the base doesn't view it.
You know, the one that Mike Penc
That's the problem for him,
though, right? Is he's trying.
I think all of these Republicans
who are not Trump
have to try and find a lane,
try and find a space and an audi
And does this connect?
Are the Republicans of the party
are interested in hearing this?
Does this message connect with p
And I think that's
still really an open question.
You know,
it's been interesting
to see
this Republican debate
play out about January six.
Kevin McCarthy
did not want to have this discus
He did not want to have
to talk about January six.
He avoided discussion about this
for much of the past two years.
But then he gave the security fo
to Tucker Carlson,
this internal security footage,
and he's been back and forth
about defending his decision
to go this route.
Just listen
to how he kept the speaker of th
Then the Republican minority lea
talked about it on January six.
And now what he's saying,
the violence
destruction and chaos we saw
earlier was unacceptable,
undemocratic and un-American.
We all should stand united
in condemning the mob together,
but each person can come up
with their own conclusion.
But I want
I just want to make sure
as I had transparency,
I mean, as McCarthy repeatedly
this week,
does he agree with the portrayal
by Tucker
Carlson that this was a a
by a mostly peaceful day,
you could not get himself to dis
publicly with Tucker Carlson.
What's your read?
You know,
he's always had a problem with t
I mean, look,
the the night of January six,
he voted against certifying Joe
Electoral College victory.
I mean, he
you know, he had 140 Republicans
So and then three weeks
later, he's down with Trump in F
after January six, he's down.
Trump had left the White House,
and McCarthy was the first perso
to go see him down
or second after Lindsey Graham.
You know, I mean, he's needs Tru
He needed Trump to be speaker.
He still needs Trump
or that element of the party.
But but this is a huge problem.
There is no alternative.
You know,
reading on January six,
it was an insurrection
attempt to overthrow the governm
But now you have, you know, Marj
Taylor Greene and a full committ
chairman, co chairman Coomer,
the Oversight Committee.
They're going to go see the Janu
six political prisoners.
I mean, this is lunacy.
This is not.
This is not the
you know,
what the country needs
And McCarthy knows
it's a problem for him,
but he just can't get himself to
get there because he's still
he can't cut off Trump.
You can't cut off the Trump
wing of the party, the MAGA wing
He can't cut it.
And just listen
to how the Republican senators
who I talked to about all of thi
how they reacted about the effor
to try to whitewash
the events of that day,
I think it's both.
I was here.
I was down there.
I don't take any part in whitewa
January six.
It wasn't a stroll through the C
It was a attack on our Capitol.
There's no question.
But the January six was a riot,
an insurrection attempt.
Efforts to try to pretend
that it was something other than
are despicable.
And frankly, dangerous.
What do you think of this
divide within the party over thi
They were all there,
and now others are downplaying i
They witnessed it
but these senators obviously
have still it's
very fresh in their minds.
Right. Right.
And it's another example of this
deep divide among Republicans,
especially when it comes to the
and the Senate.
And I do think what
you're seeing here, too, with Mc
giving Tucker
Carlson the tapes,
what Marjorie
Taylor Greene
is doing by visiting these Janua
defendants at the Capitol
is an attempt
to just rewrite
the history of January six,
which is in a very false way.
We were all there.
We witnessed that.
If we weren't physically there,
we witnessed it live on TV.
I do think some element is
that Republicans felt
Republicans were shut
out of the January six
committee process by their own d
They, I think, recognize that
that was a strategic error on th
And I do think that some of this
is trying to catch up
and trying
to rewrite the narrative again
in an inaccurate way
because of all that came out
through those committee hearings
But what was remarkable
this week, two was Mitch McConne
speaking of Republican senators,
going out there
without being prompted by questi
from what have you guys going ou
and saying,
I disagree with the interpretati
and that Tucker
Carlson put forward on Fox News
the previous night.
I mean,
we all know
Mitch McConnell, he does not pro
distance himself
from either
Fox News, the Republican base
or Kevin McCarthy like that.
So this was a really big deal
in aligning himself
with the Capitol Police chief, f
offensive and fun to cherry
picked the footage
that was aired on on FOX.
And I asked McCarthy,
the speaker, make a mistake.
He wouldn't say
if the speaker made a mistake,
but he said Fox News made a mist
which is still significant.
For someone who really carefully
guards his words.
But just as Mike
Pence comes out strongly against
Donald Trump calling on him
to overturn the election,
we heard the strongest comment
that he's made to date about thi
last night.
Donald Trump,
as on the other side,
as he has been for so long, even
this really curious song that he
with the January six prisoners a
Just take a listen
I pledge allegiance
to the flag
of the United States of America.
Are
I mean, he's
aligning himself
with the people who are in jail
for trying to overturn
and certify president.
This is exactly what worries
so many Republican
that I've been speaking to actua
They want to turn the page and m
on, talk about the economy,
talk about President Biden,
talked about other things.
And here it is
once again, talk once from our p
Back to Tucker Carlson. One quic
The bottom line, what we know no
that through the deposition
and other things,
he is worried about his audience
losing his audience.
So that, of course, is
why he's concocting this new sho
and other things.
But it's a huge divide within th
that's dangerous.
Yeah, it really and it's and it'
going to continue to play out.